[Music]
all right so you guys have seen on
Instagram a lot of people use that
platform to promote their businesses and
but apparently and I ran these men they
thought it was a good idea to use
Instagram to promote them selling babies
what baby we got a lot of baby we got
baby girl baby baby English so we what
do they get to spot like to do a
sponsored ad for the baby sale is this
like a child trafficking yeah mmm
exactly
for sex what I don't know about that
creepy-ass people be buying babies on
the black market what happens well some
people just buy them because it's
cheaper than an adoption yeah that's
what I was thinking but then you brought
up sex
wait so trafficking means it has to be
for sex not are usually sex trafficking
yeah
child trafficking is usually child to
child sex trafficking that's why when I
mix the two it sounds like we're in some
drug trafficking sometimes like where
the kids have to yeah they're the mule
yeah yeah this is this is babies babies
not have not really heard about baby
trafficking before yeah I mean like for
the babies so there will be babies that
either like really really really poor
families that they just can't even like
take care of this baby they'll sell it
off to people like this mm-hmm and then
so now there's like then they get my
conceptually understood yeah so the
person who buys the baby ends up selling
it to a family that are hopefully a
family that's trying to get a baby and
hopefully not the other stuff so they're
like the middleman baby up sellers
they're like a
facts but for babies Connor right it's
also so prevalent that they put two
ankle alarm things on the baby when
they're born so when I co was born I've
heard of people like snatching babies so
they put one thing on the ankle so it's
the minute the baby leaves the whatever
the mom's bracelet I think I kinda on
both of his ankles
oh I mean like like if it's event it
gets far away from the mom I think isn't
it yeah the word socio say like if the
minute the baby leaves award alarm goes
off like someone's trying to snatch a
baby but she was putting on too and I my
oh how come there's two shields cuz
that's how often it happened with
someone watch to try to snip it off oh
yeah because they can't be like to
America in America this is Pasadena baby
Snatchers everywhere everywhere oh my
eyeballs on that baby oh yeah yeah cute
yeah we're gonna call pink pig silver is
when there's an elderly person missing
horn I'm sorry this is no I don't wait
called servers when someone has a gun I
forgot I forgot these cool anyway yeah
there's like a hallway so confusing
what was that color legend room yeah
yeah I got a person they have it all
over the hospital the legend of the
codes yeah man like who the [ __ ] out
there's baby shopping his [ __ ] like you
know right because babies on Google or
like know it's crazy but so apparently
they were trying to sell a 20 day old
baby that's so [ __ ] sad he doesn't two
month old child so these two kids they
were rescued from this like online
selling ring and apparently there have
there is a third baby but they still
haven't caught like found or rescued the
baby but yeah these guys are trying to
sell three babies and they were
advertising it on social media they're
saying that one was being advertised for
four hundred million reals which is like
nine thousand four hundred and ninety
dollars and then the other one where you
could buy a life for nine genes crazy
yeah
for 11800 some German Shepherds thank
you
you know it's crazy he bought the baby
so like um someone bought it yes so they
bought one of the babies for a thousand
one hundred like this is how desperate
the families were because before did
selling into the middleman yeah okay Wow
they sold it for a thousand one hundred
and then the other one was two thousand
three hundred that's insane you know
when he had the Great Depression here
people were giving out and selling their
kids too there are like pictures of
people like on their stair stair wall or
whatever like in New York and then
they'll say kids for sale it's [ __ ]
crazy too but the people that buy those
it's like that's where it's scary where
they go in yeah it's like hopefully were
their intentions I'm hoping is like a
family like we did one on in China where
this couple adopted a kid and they
bought the baby from like a baby dealer
but the kid grew up normally and then he
found his like birth mother and they're
trying to reconnect but they just
couldn't have kids but they wanted one
real reason because they didn't focus on
that story but he was bought from a baby
snatcher because like let's say they had
good intentions right like they're like
wanna raise this kid normal well you
can't do that if this person is not
gonna have a social security number they
can only like have one if they're
registered but then it's like they knew
the u.s. is in rural China right that's
what I'm that's oh because it might be
like maybe they don't have adoption
firms and Iran or underground people can
easily pull up a [ __ ] social security
card and of course you take it like Phil
Felisa no worries because when I was in
Thailand too and they were teaching us
about like I was traveling with my
church and doing mission trips and what
they were saying is that like in these
poor villages in in northern Thailand
they're not high people with citizenship
they're like Hmong people or like
they're just not they don't have papers
and then sometimes they don't have money
for the village or families are
extremely poor so then a recruiter will
come and be like oh yeah they could work
in the city like my friend has a factory
will take care of them and they're just
like village people they don't know and
they're like how that'll be really good
right and then they'll send their
daughter
and she goes and she gets into sex
slavery right and then so the girl is so
ashamed of what she got herself into
that she can't go back to her family and
then it's pretty [ __ ] up right so once
we learned of this whole process it was
like oh [ __ ] so there's so many people
that are getting taken advantage to
because of how broke they are and how
hungry they are yeah it's pretty sad
there's this one group though I thought
it was so [ __ ] dope I forgot the name
of it but it's like current and former
people in professional law-enforcement
agencies from local police military CIA
and all these guys right and they go out
and they find missing children and child
trafficking organizations and then they
take them the [ __ ] out it's it's so dope
there's a group called Guardian group
that's like that no Tim Kennedy is know
so Tim Kennedy is a former UFC fighter
also former Green Beret
so he's like special ops so he's just
like the he's probably like the closest
thing we have to a superhuman GI Joe
[ __ ] and he has I think he has a
company called Guardian group that
transpeople down and stops sex
trafficking I want to do that really
this le reminds me of a Jeffrey Epstein
thing did you guys see that netflix
document only watching first episode so
far oh man it's uh well I guess point is
everybody remembers that moment you know
I mean when he randomly did not die
didn't kill himself or whatever you know
in this maximum-security washed prison
or whatever but you know the whole thing
just being about like his connections to
help like this underground child sex
trafficking international hype like
high-carb profile players you know what
I mean going to his private islands you
know involving people like Bill Clinton
involving people like Trump you know and
it's just then the trail just goes off
right it just disappears because he's
dead and that's it end of story what was
that pedo gate the day you sent I still
haven't seen it
oh yeah I mean it's just basically a
like it has to do with all that stuff
how they're like the globalist elites
have a like a pedophile thing and it's
like tied into Satanism and cannibalism
like they believe performing certain
rituals gives them power and it's like
almost too far-fetched for you to like
believe but then some [ __ ] comes out
like the Epstein stuff and you're like
this [ __ ] is real like there's real [ __ ]
and then there's stories from Hollywood
people who have maybe been invited to
these parties and then they like got out
and they're like yeah there's some crazy
[ __ ] going on so there's too many
reports to like dismiss but then it's so
far-fetched you can't like picture your
favorite celebrities participating in
this like Satanist culture but then
that's that's the whole thing is like
it's very secret and anyone who has come
out with information has gotten killed
or randomly committed suicide randomly
got in a car accident
randomly had like something on their
hard drive but they swear wasn't on
there and got locked away to prison to
present so it's interesting it's a very
like crazy rabbit hole you could find
yourself in at 3:00 in the morning if
you go down the internet I've been there
yeah many many times
you know there's um the US they they
have a list of the worst offenders on
human trafficking and like tier 3 is
where Iran is so there's different
countries
yeah different country is Tier one the
higher what I were talking about like
people yeah I know
Epstein is number three yeah well who's
number one day and [ __ ] yes sorry I
didn't clarify talking about countries
yeah
so there's 21 countries and tier 3 like
that's like the worst and but that is
the worst how come is not here one so
tier one is like first level and in
three is the top I guess it's kind of
like first world second world third
world probably is how they probably do
okay so tier ones almost like this
country has minimal child may be
kidnapping problems and then and then
third is yeah exactly so then they're
saying that countries listed in this
tier do not
Fuli of me do not fully meet the minimum
standards for the elimination of
trafficking and are not making any
efforts to do so so Iran is one of them
Saudi Arabia Cuba yeah North Korea
Venezuela China Russia Syria South Sudan
China makes sense cuz that news was out
remember the baby got stolen and then
sold to that farming family yeah and
then they just raised them yeah it's
like we need a kid I could get you a kid
you got 600 bucks sure it goes hey we
got somebody to pick the [ __ ] of
cauliflower now yeah that's crazy that's
crazy yeah that's [ __ ] nuts man oh I'm
just so glad for this particular story
we're talking about what the three
babies I'm glad to at least got rescued
yeah Louie find that third baby soon man
that pedal gate rabbit hole can get you
into a really dark place though but I
think the cool thing about it is there
are groups like the guardians or
whatever that are out there trying to
catch a lot of these guys and I think as
more people find out that this [ __ ] is
real because even the British Parliament
I think recently got caught for
legitimate child section what they were
yeah and then there's like people that
came out and said like yeah I went to
that house and then pointing out and it
all got under a brush under the rug and
it's like the Duke of York was involved
in the epstein thing as well
Prince Andrew yeah yeah yeah there's a
there's a documentary that's sometimes
Google or YouTube shadow bans it
apparently but it's called out of the
shadows that people were like passing
around and like I feel like that's a
good entry if you're like into or like
yeah if you're like you've never heard
anything and you're like I want to know
what that's about
that's like a good yeah that's awesome
like a dark web type stuff though it's
like everybody knows about the dark web
but like nobody knows it go inside is
like you don't know jack and that's
that's even the topic of conversation I
feel like when we have with like these
high profile people because no matter
even though you
he's like you know guerrilla troops of
people that are trying to let go out and
do justice and you know fight the fight
the system or not but these people that
are in these rings are like a such high
power you know what I mean they they
have like so much resource so much
access so much protection so much money
so much blah blah blah blah blah and
it's like hey that's what makes it a
really dark place right through the top
1% of all the wealth in the world
[Music]
[Music]